the last one this is Tyler Evans okay
walking alone is elin night there and I
got cocaine it is gang gang but who what
do you say from the beginning
he's from New Zealand and walking alone
at night walking alone at night good way
to meet women good way good way to meet
death good way to get right dude oh
you're gonna smile walking on tonight my
head's on a swivel
yeah a heads on a swivel dude yeah
walking alone at night it's very
old-fashioned I feel like yeah yeah yeah
it's kind of something that you don't do
anymore because people always get killed
doing it we're great yeah it's like it's
almost like you know the consequences
yeah even the guys could commit the
crimes like you're the one that's
walking I'm gonna do it but I just see
no one's out here forever just happy
yeah why are you do you ask for this I
didn't want to do this you knew when you
came out walking down the shore on your
own yeah you have to goddamn life it's
so dangerous but I guess it because
here's the thing most people do it the
only people still doing it or criminals
or people that are peeping tom errs
we're looking for drugs yeah yeah I also
you walk in that night yeah Brian
[ __ ] walking for nothing bro what are
you doing out there do you get the buddy
system looking for trouble dude hold
your buddy's hand you're looking to get
murdered you're looking to get lit up by
a couple of men dude here's the other
thing I think about you do the buddy
system say mean you're walking down the
street holding hands there's me a hate
crime yeah you can't even do the buddy
system anymore do you think it gay rude
and you keep growing your hair out
I keep growing my hair now I think it's
to [ __ ] walking down Hollywood
Boulevard we're getting beat up dude
no do you think about that make sure you
keep that hat on what what just happened
basically you can't walk down the street
especially you and me if we keep growing
our hero
I think if you gotta have a sword or
something with you you have to be
prepared these days if you're gonna walk
in at night cuz everybody else are
prepared
nobody's milling around at night going
for a stroll if they are it's a setup
dude yeah to set up they're looking for
drugs they have drugs nobody's like oh
yeah my dog ran off or something there's
none of that [ __ ] going on any nothing
good has come from walking at night
alone yeah
never yeah so Richard Simmons try to
pick me up one time they do in Hollywood
yeah it's awesome and we're at right
outside the comedy store yeah I pulled
up I was like oh you big boys like who
the hell is that there's him in a white
Land Rover oh we had a great night
you're big who's that big biscuit okay
some energy haha so I'm gonna say I like
it it feels adventurous when you do it
it feels like you could do something
crazy or something crazy could happen
feels like you could do anything if you
walk it alone by a night and finally get
to your destination I love walking past
somebody's house seeing like a family in
their window or something to see them
living and they don't even know that you
[ __ ] exist just be who you want to be
a piece of their mail or some [ __ ] do
you do whatever you want dude take a
piece of their [ __ ] windowsill take
still one there avocados were you up in
Salinas dude this family has avocados
outside night your gangster King it
broke get out I can't cuz it's living
it's also you're gonna be a badass if
you don't see the world man walk at
night
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]